All right, guys, so this is going to be the last lecture of the course update in this video in this lecture
We're going to talk about how to do proper risk management for passing the
problem challenges and also how to keep the account that you pass, okay?
You see a lot of these people have that they have infinite amount of you know,
problem accounts and you wonder why you still don't have one, right?
It's it's because they have a different approach to these accounts. They have a different risk management strategy
for problem challenges. That's why they have so many accounts. It's not that they don't blow up their challenges, right?
Even I do sometimes. I don't I don't yeah, it happens with every single trader
All right, it's not that if you fail the problem challenge you are an unsuccessful trader. No, it's not the case
10 percent in 30 days or 8 percent 30 days is absolutely insane, okay?
And it's like 60 to 50 percent chance that you can attain that
a
normal
Experienced well-mounted trader is going to only be able to do 4 to 5 percent or 6 percent max per month
But 8 percent is way too much or 10 percent is way too much, but we have a risk management for this
For passing the problem challenges. So on the face one, right? The very first face. Our goal is to win two trades in a row, right?
Then risk one person on your first trade and go for one to two rr, okay?
So let's say you win your first trade if you win the trade
Then you take the second trade and risk two percent and go for one to three if both trades hit tp
You will get eight percent, which is enough to pass the phase one, right?
So on when you are on break even right you start your fresh account
You risk one percent and go for one to two goal here is to win that trade
You have to look for an eight plus setup the best setup possible
Win that trade you will get one to two. So now you have a buffer, right?
now
If you win that trade you will have two rr in your account now for the second trade, right?
You want to find an eight plus setup as well and risk two person for that and go for one to three, right?
So you go for one to three that would be six percent and two percent from the first trade that is eight person
You will pass most of the profit from challenge. However for fdmo what you can do here is you risk one person, right?
You have two percent
Then you take another
You risk one person again, right?
You get four person profit and then you can go for one to three
So three days it's going to take for you to pass the fdmo challenge. So the third trade is going to be two percent
If you lose the first trade and our blowbreak even keep risking one person until you are up by two person and then risk two person
So the thing here is let's say you lose your first rate, right?
It can happen you keep on risking one percent until you are in profit by two person and once you are in up by two person you risk
Two person for the next trade and you're gonna get and you're gonna go for one to three, right?
You normally will go keep on going for one to two
But once you are up by two percent, you go for one to three by risking two percent. You will get eight percent for phase two
Once you pass the phase one for phase two how to pass that?
So risk one person on your first trade and go for one to two risk reward, right?
If you win the trade take the second trade and risk one person and go for one to three
If both trades hit tp you will get five percent, which is enough to pass the phase two
If you lose the first trade and our blowbreak even keep risking one person until you are up by two person
And then risk one person again until you and go for one to three, right?
So the for the first trade we go for one to two and for the second trade we go for one to three
You have to find the eight plus setups for both of these trades, right?
I don't care about the rest of the trades, but for the first two trades you have to find the best possible setups guys, all right?
So that's pretty much it. So now how do you keep your account, right? Let's say that you have paused these two accounts
You have to risk
zero point five percent per trade on your funded account
All right, you have to do that and once you are up by let's say one person or two percent in profits
you risk one person
Right and if you lose you go back to let's say a break even
You then risk zero point five until you are up by
One or two percent, right? So let's say you are up by one person you risk one person, right?
And you go for one to two once you get
One to two you are in three kip profit, right? Three three thousand dollars on hundred k account
You just withdraw that profit. Don't go for more
Trust me. Don't go for more. Just get these tiny profits and get out
Go and buy another challenge phase and keep on building your account your your funded account, right?
How many accounts you have you have to keep on building that don't just be stuck on one single account and don't be greedy, right?
If you see like two to three k per month on a hundred k account has more than enough guys
That's what I do. That's why you see me taking
Way two less trades every single month because I'd only need two to three percent. That's it
so
When you start out risk zero point five percent per trade
Once you are in one percent or two percent profit
So let's say that you are in two percent profit
You have to risk one percent, right?
If you are in one percent profit, you also risk one person
So let's say you are in one percent profit. You lose that trade. It's totally fine
You have you are at back at breakeven. So now you keep risking zero point five till you're back at one person
Once you're back at one person percentage right profits
You risk that one person and go for one to two and wise worse that guys
So that's pretty much it about about it guys. I really hope that you guys
Learn something from this course update. Of course, they're gonna be more course updates in the future
But for now this is what you need to become an independent trader
Go and back test back test and back test don't go on the live charts, right? You need to back test and you need to be confident
I'll see you guys in the next course update. I'll see you guys on youtube
In some days. So love you guys. Hope you guys have a great night or day
Enjoy and yeah, thank you so much for watching and
Bye-bye